hey Jeremy
okay so place okay get closer can you
see me
I know okay I photographed you remember
I photographed you a while back please
it is your world with this didn't you
call
yeah that's it you I took you to Culver
City hey goo how you been good how you
been okay down we all want to say that
your car and call City studio yeah and
you dis arrest list that's right
yeah that yeah it's on the walls oh come
off cool it's important or not great
next time I see you I'll show we talked
several times now but I don't really
know exactly the full details of what
happened to you
five years ago okay I would see that
bust up were little mood were they a
couple moves later I woke up in the
hospital but I was dreaming doctor told
me that was sad to say a hit for Sega he
said the only reason I survived because
he was playing black lanes he said it
was not point bein rich rage but here we
go down the street and you'd be dead
have you dead yet and see I can't see I
got this left eye but no I cannot smell
agree that at all and the skin here came
up with egg who they prepared rub right
here you see this right here see this is
my right this right here so in here
that's my right here and you here right
here right is this
they put its coma like that man very
touching situate it's a natural is it
someone right in here he did something
really the expert right here this right
here yeah
I'm gonna say they put school stuff down
long sure I wouldn't doubt you got
screws in there
yeah well for brains though
did you break it down it went down to be
severe you got to be you see your
Grainger's hater to out to here like
it's Dino kid
hey you have my face Hey
yeah it's oh yeah let's remove it yeah
yeah it's my way before my see you're
back man you're very brave
that's the back way that's what you
think with movement do all this way yeah
that was my bad way you always ride I'm
happy the wheelchair I proved today that
some guys which I do the tongue before
you've been shot your life you probably
like you know till night you know as you
be able to see this
it's make every port plus that machine
shop yeah yeah this is yeah this happen
take my bleep I can't you a good day
right yeah that's good so you're still
dangerous neighborhood yeah that's it
nice with the film quit Billy oh you're
the first Street
yeah the corner the industry we're
business people would see the key you
can't see through the sidewalk is it
secured you a student I tend that is
okay by God I glad you at six o'clock
boys oh yeah guys get down here the way
are you are you frustrated or bitter or
angry about what happened to you I can't
help it so I accept it
you are always this way or you come to a
setback I've been this way no way
later and you realize you're missing the
right side of your face and brain and
that's the old weekend I'm gonna take
some notes I would tape myself and about
two years I was introduced to reconcile
myself I know two years
how's your you see that you can't see
this right here
yeah look at myself over two years ago
nobody I said yeah well there's that but
I said except that you know they keep
Moodle yeah have to me I can't change it
I can't stop moving in sometimes you
have you like you can help you a bit yet
Cheers people were scared John that's
some here to me so kids right they could
talk to be healthy and summer cry ya
know the water to be high it's okay how
you doing okay bye bye so scarce of that
some people before we were scared some
night you know vice versa so who was
they don't know I can't last everyone is
the best time and when I know with the
best outfit did that was in that was out
of that they said and he said I had 23
hours surgery 23 hours that was doing 24
hours surgery 23 officer
yeah they said I see jewels me they will
talk customizations for us each one I'm
sorry
they say drew has invited us your
c-murder they said then were the top
three hospitals in Basin at for his ear
trunk they would say yeah wait Thomas
baby every trouble yet with that one guy
say he see me he's a man I read about
you
he said they got you in American
political history book first invited
would happen to you yeah he said me this
other lady feel about that lady that
they surpassed ripped her face off with
some like that I gave her
it's you're being heard in a miracle
American history history book yeah they
can really survive whatever to us yeah
amazing so it's kind of derail survived
it
sim rather though say gets its way there
I get the other that let's go to the
room things I do
it lays that respectively so I will take
this later to to deposit
those advices
if you trust a guy that's always bad
that guy did you trust a guy like
simplicity God We Trust
keep your trusty guy he's the way to
write the truth and the only only way
that's it did you like being a they say
it but definitely sir
let the new of the cell we have nothing
new Under the Sun that's the Bible
she was happy today happy DC you'll be
see me before the birth of Christ we
have this one after all it says back
then was going today say anyway back
today's same thing so I says nothing new
Under the Sun they say that it is it
which mere years will go by like much
but we go by like weeks and weeks will
go by like days and you will that do
your summer are you winning at speed of
all time we don't which will do it at
all in the back of it that's all about
what do you look forward to down the
road for you happiness yeah that is
amazing you have to you have to add your
head
Yankees Joey yeah that'd be great
lucky I can't let this bring me down all
excuse in the world to see it to be dead
everything like that you saying this is
rather I won't use it said you don't say
tell you that is this the way I'm just
best to be alive and that's the glass
will be so happy I can't be there me the
others we did that their friend that's
it are you giving works
look alive but enough in the nursery
butcher he's there telling you around so
like that can maybe see myself or
anything like that
barely a vessel or something and I've
been that way but God can't be spared my
life that's which is great Jerry you're
beautiful man yeah this is great guys
good
stay with me every day what time is it
it is 47 - hopefully 10 I'll take Gary
yes